[Music]
what a difference one game makes coming
out of sunday's classic win over the
ravens where we saw patrick mahomes with
the no look pass followed immediately by
the kent to calvi sidearm throw followed
eventually by that incredible deep throw
with the game on the line fourth and
nine forty plus yards to tyree kill
patrick mahomes is our mvp
now
and and remember the point i made chris
patrick holmes has two prime time games
back to back so he's either going to
earn it or he's going to lose it and
last night it looked like he was
cementing his case early on he was doing
patrick mahomes things early in the game
as the chiefs built a 14 nothing lead
and then by the end of the game
i'm thinking philip rivers is our mvp
where do you see it right now and how
important will the next few weeks be
well first thing was it was awesome i
think you'd agree to sit there and watch
what patrick mahomes was doing
and then watch philip rivers reactions
off that right we haven't talked about
that you know someone after that what
was that the first touchdown pass where
he was being dragged to the ground and
then flicked it you know sidearm for a
touchdown pass and like to see phillip
rivers like wow and some of the comments
that he must have made to troy aikman
and publicly during the week such a cool
moment that felt that philip rivers
could tuck away his ego there and go man
this guy's special i enjoy watching him
on film i watch film and go i can't do
that that's amazing you saw the way he
reacted to patrick mahomes after the
game
i still think mahomes is the mvp uh he's
been the best player in football all
year long for my money i do think
phillip rivers is right there kind of
nipping at his heels but
i just think on a game by game basis
nobody has wowed us and ought us more
than patrick mahomes and what he's done
and he has taken this offense and team
to the next level and that's why they
are where they are remember there's no
kareem hunt sammy watkins has been hurt
for a lot of the year so
i would argue to you that his weapons
are not as good as phillip rivers so i
would also say philip rivers is two and
then it becomes aaron donald drew brees
conversation right there as the next you
know three-four part of that convo
yeah but phillip rivers hasn't had
hunter henry all year i that's all i'm
going to say about that um so
you can you've got philip rivers you've
got patrick mahomes
and who beyond them is still viable
right now and because i look at it this
way because future games really are
going to change how we think if mahomes
and the chiefs go to seattle and beat
the seahawks we're going to feel
differently about my homes again and if
the chiefs end up with the number one
seat i think it's easier to make the
case from a homes but if they end up not
as the number one seed if they're the
five seed it's harder to make the case
for mahomes but who beyond my homes and
rivers would you look to is still being
a viable candidate well the two guys i
said there donald and brees you know i
do think brees's you know recent
performances certainly have hurt him a
little bit aaron donald's the guy i look
at that could maybe come in here and
steal the show i mean if he comes out on
sunday night and gets another three
sacks or something like that which could
is very possible against this eagles
offense and i think this eagles offense
will be playing from behind most of the
night you know then we get into 19 and a
half sacks and we go whoa there's two
games left and i look at aaron donald as
the guy if he gets up to around 21 22 or
breaks the sack record he could be the
one that upsets this whole thing and
steals the mvp race from from a mall
homes or a phillip rivers or breeze when
all said and done
i think donald has to set the single
season sack i think he has to do it tie
it right he has to set it or tie it
because if he ties it
he'll essentially have said it because
there's that big giant asterisk on the
michael strahan sack record from when he
got the gift from brett favre right so i
think he's got to get 22 and a half or
more if he does that then i think he can
win the mvp especially if some of these
other guys are cooling off we saw drew
brees cool off a couple of weeks ago
against the cowboys we saw todd gurley
and jared goff both take a step back on
sunday night against the bears now
mahomes after starting great last night
the chiefs lost if they end up the five
seed that hurts him will philip rivers
be compelling enough to get to the top
of the stack it could come down to a
couple of la guys it could be rivers
versus donald by the time it's all said
and done the only thing i don't like
about it and i feel bad about this
because i used to clamor for it back
before they changed the timing of when
they announced it i i used to say let's
have some sort of event where they
announce all the awards but they waited
now until the night before the super
bowl i hate that they do that because by
the time we are the night before the
super bowl i don't care anymore about
the postseason awards i wish they would
do something sooner in time to the end
of the regular season before the
playoffs really get rolling before the
super bowl participants are locked in i
i agree i think you're right there i
think that should be something like wild
card weekend that should happen
something like that to where there's the
unveiling of the the mvp a little bit
like the nba right that's how they do it
they give the mvp trophy into a playoff
game usually as the guy's about to play
it uh so i agree it's another moment too
to celebrate that player throughout the
last few weeks of the playoffs or
whatever it may be i also think it puts
more pressure on that player and i like
watching the the pressure of the mvp
kind of you know squirm in in the
playoffs and have to deal with that you
know title being you know above his head
or his name either way but again i do
think mahomes the year he's had the
amount of times he's made you and me go
whoa that's unbelievable on sunday
afternoons and again i would like to
remind everybody that alex smith in the
same offense last year with i would
argue better weapons because at least
albert wilson was out there last year
and sammy watkins is not and he's going
to end up throwing for twice as many
touchdown passes as alex smith did in
the same exact offense i think that
shows you how special he is
well you know there is a way to give
patrick mahomes recognition without
making him the mvp you making the
offensive player of the year a
distinction that i still will not
understand yeah i think that's there so
the voters can have some sort of a
compromise if there are two viable
candidates one's the mvp and the other
is the offensive player of the year and
we'll just leave it at that because look
at it this way if aaron donald wins mvp
there's no way he's not defensive player
of the year
let that sink in for a second if you're
good enough to be the mvp on the
defensive side of the ball you're
definitely the defensive player of the
year but you can be the mvp
and not be the offensive player of the
year if you're a quarterback or a
running back how do you reconcile i
think that goes to your point exactly
right we're you know we're in the day
and age where we got to give a blue
ribbon to everybody you know oh you're
hey i'll stop it
that's not a good look for you stop why
i'm just saying that's where we are
because we hear that crap all the time
now oh everybody gets a trophy come on
people eventually everybody gets a harsh
dose of the real world i don't care if
you get a trophy for being in ninth
place in t-ball if people know who wins
and loses yeah well
the harsh
the harshness anymore because they're
giving trophies for coming in 12th place
sometimes so yeah they need to be taught
reality a little earlier is what i'm
saying i've seen it with my own kid okay
i'm just saying i'm not trying to be a
jerk i'm just having a convo i'm
agreeing with your point that it's
ridiculous
the mvp
is not is obviously if he's on the
offense as the offensive player of the
year but we've found some way to go oh
here's two really good guys and it's
kind of like a yeah it's like a
scapegoat almost
i just think that it's not a scapegoat i
think
it's not the word to you right i don't
know what i was trying to say there
hunter henry would be a scapegoat my
point is this the the um
the idea that that
the compromise is what is reached it has
nothing to do with finding a way to give
everyone a trophy it's finding a way
when you've got two really good players
and you want to recognize both you make
one the offensive player of the year and
you make one the mvp it's too worthy
stupid
all right yeah
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports